I mean sometimes I'm calm sometimes I'm
not Megan McCain taking aim at Meghan
Markle in an op-ed for the daily Mill
after it was announced the Duchess of
Sussex will sit out king Charles's
coronation next month I think it's a
safe solution given all the drama that
we've seen over the past year or two
McCain calls Markle and husband Prince
Harry whiny ingrates as she sees it
Marco's chickening out amid the royal
family drama she is clearly unwilling to
face the music with her in-laws they are
destroying us my first reaction is
relief that Harry is going to be at his
father's coronation on Wednesday it was
revealed that Harry will be on hand for
the big day but without Megan the reason
well the coronation is on May 6th the
same day as Prince Archie's fourth
birthday and she'll be at their
Montecito home with Archie and lilibet
it's an excellent reason for her to sort
of wriggle out of going to the UK to
what will be for her uncomfortable
situation but McCain doubles down they
couldn't celebrate in the UK adding I'm
not buying it Megan is incredibly media
Savvy and I think that she's going to
follow the same pattern of laying low
that we saw when Harry did his major
press tour I think this book has been a
cathartic experience for me following
the drama surrounding his Memoir could
the coronation be a chance for Harry to
mend the Royal Rift according to Mccain
not anymore I fully expect Harry to just
jet in and out for this event I don't
think he's comfortable in the UK quote
this demolishes Harry and Megan's claim
that they're interested in
reconciliation Charles and William
they're going to be pulled in a million
different directions it would be
extraordinary to think they would have
even a minute with Harry to even say
hello let alone heal the Royal Rift
anyone inside that system whether it's
my family whether it's staff whether
it's PR whoever it is is have already
missed an enormous opportunity with my
wife
and how far that would go globally I
think there's bound to be some relief
from William and Kate that Megan won't
be attending the coronation simply
because less emphasis is going to be on
them who's looking where what's going on
between them all there's such a fever of
interest in these relationships
foreign